[Musik]
anlass dem dialog ist richard david
precht er ist der autor bestseller autor
philosoph und es ist ihm gelungen mit
philosophischen büchern ein
millionenpublikum zu erreichen
schön dass sie da sind dann gucken wir
erstmal auch die aktuelle lage
und da ist man schnell bei der spd die
spd hat ihren wahlkampf in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch davor unter den
begriff gerechtigkeit gestellt ist damit
dreimal jetzt ziemlich baden gegangen
taugt gerechtigkeit als thema eher für
philosophische kolloquien als für eine
klitsche kampagne
das ist eine schwierige frage also
erstmal ist gerechtigkeit in der tat ein
sehr schwieriger begriff weil wir es
keine absolute gerechtigkeit gibt
sondern nur gefühlte gerechtigkeit oder
wenn man es etwas klarer aus präpariert
es gibt in unserer gesellschaft ein
liberales konzept von gerechtigkeit das
besagt gerecht ist es wenn jeder die
gleiche chance erhält egal was am ende
dabei rauskommt dass das bürgerliche
oder liberales liberale verständnis und
das andere ist das sozialistische
verständnis das sagt gerecht ist wenn am
ende jeder das gleiche kräfte und alle
gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen unserer
gesellschaft ist immer der versuch
zwischen diesen beiden polen ein spagat
herzustellen soziale marktwirtschaft ist
der versuch dieser vermittlung nur was
hier jetzt genau als gerecht empfinden
gerade im hinblick auf unseren blick auf
andere irgendwo auf dieser skala ist bei
jedem menschen anders und das macht es
so schwer in gerechtigkeit zweikampf zu
führen bei dem runden gibt es nur
gefühlte gerechtigkeit und
ungerechtigkeit
das heißt so wie der begriff und
differenziert benutzt wird ist er hier
so eine projektionsfläche für alles und
nichts
hier ist eine projektionsfläche ist
natürlich richtig also wenn man sagt es
gibt immer mehr reiche in diesem land
auf der einen seite und es gibt eine
große zahl von abgehängten die keine
funktionäre haben an der gesellschaft zu
partizipieren
deren kinder von anfang an so in
bildungsfernen milieus geboren werden
dass sich eine gerechte chance im leben
halten das ist alles richtig
die frage ist nur wenn ich hier sitze
und ein wahlkampf machen und sagen wir
brauchen mehr gerechtigkeit dann
klappt's schon alle
denn das würde jede partei
das ist also kein unterscheidungsmerkmal
der spd von anderen parteien dass sie
jetzt die partei ist der ich vertrauen
soll dass sie mehr gerechtigkeit
herstellt als jede andere partei das tut
zumal man sagen muss die spd von vier
jahren ausnahmen abgesehen seit sehr
sehr langer zeit in der regierung und
wenn sie jetzt eine gerechtigkeit
zweikampf macht dann macht sie ja auch
wahlkampf gegen ihre eigene politik also
sie ist nicht die partei der liebe sogar
abnehmen dass sie stärker sich für
gerechtigkeit einsetzt als andere hatte
die spd einen kanzlerkandidaten der mit
einer geradezu atemberaubenden
zustimmung gewählt worden ist als
kandidat 100 prozent das ist nicht zu
überbieten
er hat die gerechtigkeit auch auf seine
fahnen geschrieben ist denn schon
erkennbar ob er sozusagen die ergebnis
gerechtigkeit will also am ende haben
alle die gleichen verhältnisse unter
denen sie leben können oder ist er
jemand der sagt ich setze auf
chancengerechtigkeit also welches
gerechtigkeit konzept verfolgt er das
wage ich nicht zu beurteilen also mir
ist bislang nicht genau klar geworden
mit welchen mitteln die sozialdemokratie
im falle eines wahlsieges für mehr
gerechtigkeit sorgen will
also alles was ich bisher mit kriege
sind relativ kleine dreierreihen an der
einen frau oder anderen schraube aber
die ursachen für die das immer weiter
auseinandergehen von arm und reich
das zu bekämpfen sei eine ausgesprochen
schwierige angelegenheit und das ist mit
dem bisher bekannten sozialdemokratische
mittel noch nicht möglich also setzte
ich jetzt eine vermögenssteuer machen
oder eine erbschaft feuer
die meisten leute werden die nicht sein
also jeder der so viel vermögen hat dass
er davon betroffen ist weiß wie er das
macht dass er sie nicht sein kann
also müsste man überlegen ob sie haben
unser besteuerungssystem nicht völlig
verändern muss
also ich selber persönlich würde sagen
wir müssen in zukunft immer weniger
arbeit besteuern auch weil es weniger
arbeit in der gesellschaft geben wird
und wir müssen in erster linie
finanztransaktionen besteuern also
stellen wir uns eine
finanztransaktionssteuer von zwei
prozent auf jede finanztransaktion vor
also in den geldautomaten 100 euro
abheben dann müssen sie zwei davon
abrücken würde eine unglaubliche summe
geldes generiert es würde
finanzspekulation unnötig
beziehungsweise nicht mehr lukrativ
machen und das wäre zum beispiel eine
revolutionäre idee wie man mehr
gerechtigkeit ist sein könnte denn diese
zwei prozent für ein milliardär sind
natürlich was anderes als die zwei
prozent für den kleinen mann der 100
euro abheben wenn man sich martin schulz
anschaut und seine auftritte verfolgte
fällt auf dass er eine sehr kraftvolle
rhetorik hat aber eine die manchmal so
ein bisschen wirkte wie aus der zeit
gefallen also wenn man sich erinnert an
vergangene jahrzehnte und spd
wahlveranstaltungen dann war das immer
ein appell an eine große
massenorganisation sich hinter ihr der
jeweiligen führungsfigur zu fahren es
war ein appell an menschen die
organisiert waren in gewerkschaften die
ansprache galt in erster linie
industriearbeiterschaft und anderen an
den hart arbeitenden menschen passt das
noch in die zeit oder ist es ein
bisschen aus der zeit gefallen
es ist aus der zeit gefallen ist weil es
in deutschland ich hart arbeitenden
menschen gibt aber wenn wir anderen
frauen in welche richtung sich die
gesellschaft bewegt dann müssen wir
einmal feststellen dass das was früher
das proletariat war das sind heute die
hartz 4 empfänger also das sind die
sechs oder sieben millionen
transferempfänger in diesem land das
sind die abgehängten der gesellschaft
das ist nicht mehr das proletariat also
wir heute als facharbeiter einen guten
job gehört eben nicht zu den abgehängten
der gesellschaft da hat sich schon mal
massiv verschoben
das zweite ist wir werden ein gewaltiges
struktur umbrüche in der arbeitswelt
bekommen durch die digitale revolution
die gerade erst begonnen hat diese
umbrüche werden vergleichbar groß sein
wie bei der ersten oder der zweiten
industriellen revolution das hat
gewaltige soziale folgewirkungen gehabt
beide revolutionen die erste die die
arbeiter bewegung hervor gebracht hat
aber auch zunächst mein schicksal von
millionen industriearbeitern also bauern
die neustädter kam
nicht losen hinterhof lebten und so
weiter da gab es gewaltige politische
leben
die zweite industrielle revolution also
der beginn der industriellen
serienproduktion zu anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts kulminierten
erste weltkrieg
also ich plötzlich ein pkw entstand eine
völlig moderne industriegesellschaft die
menschen lebten noch im kaiserreich und
den anderen vorstellungen und es gab
wieder ein riesen umbruch und ich möchte
dass bei der jetzigen vierten
industriellen revolution wenn ich in ein
solches chaos kommen und die gefahr ist
sehr groß dass heißt also die koordinate
wartet ein arbeiter in zehn zwanzig
jahren noch mal ganz anders aussehen das
wird vielleicht für die hälfte der
bevölkerung bei uns erst mal gar keine
arbeit mehr da sein
also es könnte sein dass sie am anfang
einer entwicklung stehen in der die
bisher bestehende arbeits und
leistungsgesellschaft durch eine andere
form von gesellschaft ersetzt wird und
bei der spd zu bleiben
gewerkschaften sind eine organisation
aus dem neunzehnten wie viele
berechtigung im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
aber wenn in zukunft kaum noch menschen
irgendwo angestellt arbeiten dann machen
gewerkschaften wie wir sie bisher
kannten keinen sinn
also müssten sich sozialdemokraten
gedanken darüber machen das machen wir
denn ganz neue arbeitswelt in den weg
bringen die spd so ein bisschen auch
opfer ihrer gründung ihres
gründungsmythos ihrer
gründungsgeschichte als arbeiterpartei
in einer gesellschaft die ein großes
arbeit her quasi beinhaltete und passt
das dann noch in die seite die stärker
von individualisierung flexibilisierung
ganz anderen herausforderungen und
geprägt ist und andere strukturen hat
als eben eine zeit die die eben von von
großen formierten massen geprägt war
wenn man kann sagen spd im 19
jahrhundert nicht nur die vertretung der
arbeiter sondern sie war auch die partei
der freiheit die die frauen zum beispiel
befreien wollte die jedem die gleichen
chancen in der gesellschaft geben
sollten und die für die
individualisierung eingetreten ist also
gegen das graue her der arbeiter wollte
sie das recht eines jeden arbeiters auf
ein selbstbestimmtes anlagen hin das
leben viel erreicht viel erreicht
aber was ist los die hätte man sagen
aber das möchte man sich genauso wie die
cdu sage und sagen also eine katholische
mission besteht im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert für die cdu auch nicht mehr
da wurde ich gerade darauf kommen wenn
man auf die konkurrenz der spd guckt
fehlt an natürlich zuerst die union auf
die cdu und die cdu die im augenblick
sehr viel erfolgreicher sind in umfragen
aber auch konkret den wahlen das machen
die anders was machen die besser finden
die die treffenderen antworten auf die
herausforderungen neben einer sehr
veränderten gesellschaft mit einer
veränderten arbeits spielt auch
überhaupt nicht also es gibt keinen
unterschied bei den beiden großen
parteien allerdings muss man die grünen
und die linke mit einrechnen also diese
von hfg gar nicht zu reden alles was in
parteien die im grunde genommen in der
gegenwart oder zum teil afd zum teil
auch linke in der vergangenheit leben
und die überhaupt keine antworten haben
auf diese gewaltigen umgestaltung der
industriegesellschaft also was besteuern
wir eigentlich wenn für die hälfte der
menschen irgendwann keine arbeit das
heißt es gibt sie sehen keine partei im
augenblick die genau diese fragen
aufnimmt und vernünftige perspektivische
antworten leider leider sehe ich das
nicht wobei man sagen muss also irgend
jemand hat angela merkel mal von einem
halben jahr gesagt was noch auf sie
haben sie große digitalisierung du musst
was in jeder rede das wort
digitalisierung benutzen das macht in
jeder rede gibt es jetzt zwei drei sätze
über digitalisierung darin sehen sie
noch keine antwort versieht keine
antwort auch die fdp hat in nordrhein
westfalen mit der digitalisierung
wahlkampf gemacht aber gemeint ist doch
nur folgendes das heißt deutschlands
wirtschaftens zukunftsfähig bleiben so
und das hier müssen wir die
infrastruktur investieren also ein
glasfaserkabel und es wäre gut wenn
jedes kind in rudeln laptop hat und in
einem foto programmieren land das ist
ungefähr das auch gerade gemeint ist das
ist nicht das wovon ich rede natürlich
ist das alles nicht falsch aber viel
entscheidender ist doch zu überlegen was
macht das eigentlich mit einer
gesellschaft wenn eine gesellschaft die
bislang daran orientiert war dass
möglichst jeder in arbeit und brot kommt
und dass der wert von menschen danach
gemessen wird was sie leisten und was
sie verdienen
das ist ja de facto von heute nicht mehr
so ja wenn sie wenn millionen von
menschen
in den größten teil ihres einkommens ja
und gar nicht mehr selber erwerben das
also die leistungsgesellschaft hat sich
so zusatz durch veralterung von außer
kraft gesetzt jetzt kommt durch die
digitale herausforderung eine welt wo
wir diesem maßstab nicht mehr anlegen
können für viele menschen einfach keine
arbeit mehr da ist sondern seit computer
roboter untereinander verletzt diese
arbeit übernehmen und das ist eine neue
gesellschaft in eine gesellschaft in der
ein alter menschheitstraum war wird die
menschen haben sehr viel mehr zeit und
müssen sehr viel weniger arbeiten
das ist ja eigentlich ein positiver
zustand nur wenn wir die nicht gestalten
dann wird es ein negativer zustand dann
haben wir ein heer von millionen und
abermillionen menschen mit einem
grundeinkommen abgespeist die keine
ideen für den tag haben in einem
bildungssystem was die menschen nicht
dazu befähigt ihn pinsel von motivation
zu gewinnen und zu pflegen
also selber pläne für den tag zu
generieren und die nicht genug einkommen
haben werden so dass wir in sozial
unruhigen zeiten kommen und nichts davon
ist jetzt im jahr 2017 wahlkampfthema
bei keiner partei und sie glauben dass
die zeit für diese aus ihrer sicht
notwendige umstellung auch unseres
denkens dass die nicht reichen wird um
rechtzeitig vorkehrungen zu treffen also
um uns darauf vorzubereiten was eben mit
der industriellen revolution also der
vierten industriellen revolution von der
sie gesprochen haben dann an
auswirkungen zu erleben sein wird das
ist richtig ja also ich erlebe dass die
parteien keine szenarien dafür entwerfen
und das ist schon aus dem grund nicht
zum wahlkampfthema machen weil wir angst
haben den leuten angst zu lernen also
lieber luden sie ein und versprechen mit
raute oder mit vielen warmen
rhetorischen orten ein gefühl von
sicherheit von beständigkeit und das
alles weitergeht wie bisher
aber damit werden karten häuser gebaut
während die erde risse bekommt und ihrer
tief führen dass es gibt ein großes
unbehagen in der bevölkerung dass
dadurch zu erklären ist dass die leute
wissen durch die globalisierung thema
flüchtlinge durch die digitalisierung
wird sich die welt rasant verändern
obwohl viele menschen in deutschland
sagen es geht uns nicht ganz gut wir
wollen ja nicht dass sie sich verändert
und das ist der grund warum im
augenblick die rückwärtsgewandten
utopien so einen zulauf haben also es
gibt heide der linkspartei sahra
wagenknecht zum beispiel die möchte am
liebsten wieder in die neunziger jahre
zurück in die zeit von willy brandt die
idee möchte in die 50er jahre zurück und
einigen hsd möchte noch zehn jahre
weiter zurück
alles das sind rät rupien aber was uns
völlig fehlt ist ein bild zu entwerfen
einer zukünftigen digitalen gesellschaft
das nicht angst macht aber dann schon
jetzt das ja zwischen retro pin wie sie
es nennen und disziplin also eigentlich
denn noch immer nach vorne gucken sagte
es wird furchtbar also ziehe ich mich
dann in ein schneckenhaus zurück und und
nun nämlich ein mit dem
rückwärtsgewandten denken an eine zeit
die ich als gut empfunden habe oder
wahrgenommen
wer genau beschrieben die gemenge lage
und die historische situation vor der
wir stehen
und dann führen wir parallel dazu
wahlkämpfe in denen es im grunde
genommen um kleinigkeiten geht
sie haben noch eins beispiel wissen sie
noch fast das wahlkampfthema vor vier
jahren war das die gemüter am meisten
erregte die sogenannte ausländer maut da
muss man sich mal überlegen hat dieses
land so wie sie das gerade auch
beschrieben habe zwischen retro pi und
die story zwischen besitzstandswahrung
und digitalen wandel keine andere sorgen
als solche themen und nehme an den
nächsten wahlkampf wird es sich wieder
auf solche kinkerlitzchen themen
hinauslaufen
das heißt also wir haben hier in diesem
land das einst ist das mit überalterung
zu kämpfen hat um zu tun hat da im
augenblick aus ihrer sicht keine keine
perspektive kann kein lösungs entwurf
wenn man den blick mal über die
landesgrenzen hinaus wirkte sehen sie
irgendwo auf der welt
von ihnen der fortgeschrittenen eine
entwicklung wo sie sagen da hat man
verstanden was auf uns zukommt mit
diesem technischen wandel und den daraus
folgenden veränderungen für die
gesellschaft und für den einzelnen
also gibt es da irgendwo ein zeichen der
hoffnung oder wir dass gesellschaften
die mimik auf die digitalisierung sehr
viel fortgeschrittener sind als
deutschland im skandinavischen länder
zum beispiel in finnland wird im
augenblick modellversuch gemacht zur
frage des bedingungslosen
grundeinkommens also wir werden diese
dinge von bereits durchgespielt von
simuliert man beschäftigt sich ernsthaft
damit und ich denke dass es so sein wird
wie immer man die skandinavischen länder
werden vorausgehen
wenn die holländer jetzt gerade nicht in
so einer schwierigen situation wären
früher war es und holland das gibt die
klassische pionierländer meistens sind
es kleine länder und dann haben wir dann
immer das gemacht was sie haben alles
gemacht haben und haben es dann
zeitversetzt gemacht aber ich denke der
ernst der lage in deutschland ist
besonders groß also muss daran denken
wir haben in deutschland und österreich
zusammen gewannen 2 millionen
arbeitsplätze automobilindustrie die
automobilindustrie wird verwenden das
autonome fahren kommt und es wird
relativ bald kommen das wird keine nicht
jahre dauern
ein riesiges problem kriegen sie wird
also auf ein minimum zusammenschrumpfen
und unser auto die konzerne werden ihr
geld mit anwendungen verdienen
sicherheit ist rief noch oder so nicht
an eine späte oder generell ja aber so
wie mir dinosaurier liegt in die waren
die dinosaurier so groß wie in der
kreidezeit kurz bevor sie ausgaben und
so ähnlich sieht das in unserem verkehr
mit den suvs aus es ist quasi der tanz
auf dem vulkan bevor kleine fruchtlose
autos kommen die wir gar nicht mehr
kaufen
das ist natürlich einen blick in die
zukunft der von manchen
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern auch sehr
bestritten dass besagtes ist also ich
erinnere an das institut der deutschen
wirtschaft und professor hüther der sagt
naja also man hat bei jeder technischen
revolution gedacht das geht an die
arbeitsplätze und der die wirtschaft
geht die arbeit aus wir haben aber de
facto eigentlich immer wieder
arbeitsplätze neue betätigungsfelder
gewonnen
auch und wir reden jetzt von arbeit als
bezahlter auch ein
also das kenne ich natürlich sehr gut
ich diskutiere sehr häufig im jahr mit
der spitzen ökonomen also zuletzt mit
ernst fehr deshalb mit der bedeutendsten
ökonomen der schweiz
letztens auch mit jemandem der zu den
wirtschaftsweisen gehört also ich kenne
die ganze argumentation aber viele auch
mit den arbeitgeberverbänden zu tun
ich wundere mich darüber dass ich
menschen die hüter der durchaus sehr
intelligent sind für diese variante des
glaubens entscheiden dahinter steht eine
folgende ökonomischer gedanke der stand
von robot solo amerikanischen
nobelpreisträger der anfang der
fünfziger jahre ein auswärts geschrieben
hat in dem er sagt der technische
fortschritt hat langfristig die
produktivität so sehr gesteigert dass
auch immer mehr arbeit entstandenes so
das hat bei den letzten drei
industriellen revolutionen geklappt
übrigens nicht immer unmittelbar
geklappt aber langfristig geklappt warum
soll das jetzt nicht so sein
und der große unterschied besteht darin
dass die anderen drei industriellen
revolutionen unter dem vorzeichen
wachsender märkte erfolgt mit jeder
industriellen revolution wurde ist
erschlossen neue absatzmärkte geschaffen
neue rohstoff märkte erobert das ist bei
der digitalisierung nicht der fall die
digitalisierung erobert keine neuen
märkte sondern sie macht die bestehenden
märkte effizient tag das ist ein ganz
großer unterschied und das ist der grund
warum dieses ökonomische modell kein
naturgesetz ist sondern nur ein
beobachtungs gesetz was dreimal unter
bestimmten faktoren geklappt hat und
jetzt beim vierten mal mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
aufgehen wird
einfaches beispiel die versicherungen
und banken werden bis zu 80 prozent
ihrer leute entlassen in den nächsten
zehn jahren
er verbraucht er noch eine bankfiliale
ja das sind noch die alten leute die
keinen computer haben in zukunft kann
man das überall abspecken bei
versicherungen sieht das ganz genauso
aus welche art von jobs wollen wir den
hochentwickelte projektmanagement jobs
jobs im quartalen sektor für diese leute
bereit stellen
das heißt also selbst wenn neue jobs
geschaffen werden wenn es so heyenn
berufe sein dass der große teil der
menschen die aus unteren und mittleren
dienstleistungsberufen aus rheine
überhaupt nicht in der lage sein werden
die jemals zu machen die
arbeitslosigkeit ist damit völlig
programm
welche jobs wären denn dann aus ihrer
sicht krisensicher also in welchen
bereichen wird es künftig noch arbeit
geben die dann auch nach unserem alten
verständnis den menschen die familie die
er davon abhängigen auch ernähren wird
es werden natürlich alle bereiche seien
in dem bei entweder wert darauf legen
dass das handarbeit ist die menschen
gemacht haben das ist das hochwertige
handwerk also in zukunft werden die
meisten fertigungs stoffe aus dem 3d
drucker kommen aber sich ein
marmorfußboden in seinem badezimmer
legen
das wird möchte man kein marmor aus dem
3d drucker es wird also vaters sei nicht
des handwerks zu hause viel teurer
werden und die antrags rufe werden
entsprechend begehrt werden dann sind es
alle die drobs wo wir sehr viel lieber
mit menschen zu tun haben wollen als mit
maschinen also ich glaube auch in 20
jahren werden im kindergarten kein
roboter eingesetzt liegende seine rolle
in der pflege pflege werden wer für
unser eingesetzt werden und da werden
wir große gesellschaftliche diskussionen
haben
bis wohin also dass ich ein in einem
pflegeheim einen patienten mit hilfe
eines roboterarms ins bett hebe ist ja
nicht verkehrt dass ich ihn aber ist
komplett in eine digitale welt einlud ja
wo es statt eines pflegers eine tapete
mit ihm redete und zu sein individuelles
fernsehprogramm macht die das zum teil
in japan von ist das ist etwas was wir
nicht wollen
also das wird sehr spannend sein aber
ich werde es versuchen gärtner geben wie
es auch kindergärten geben wird und es
gibt eine ganze reihe von berufen lehrer
wird das auch noch ganz von sichern
also ich könnte mir vorstellen wie die
hälfte der berufsbilder ist die tatsache
dass das auch noch in 20 jahren menschen
machen werden gesichert
aber wenn es die hälfte ist die die
wegfallen
dann ist das natürlich etwas was hat
dieses land noch nie in seiner
geschichte erlebt
was bedeutet das denn dann für eine
gesellschaft das kann doch nur mit mit
wahnsinns turbulenzen verbunden sein mit
auch sehr gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen wenn eine
gesellschaft in zwei gruppen zur welt in
der die ein irgendwie von ihrer arbeit
dann leben können und die andere hälfte
beschäftigungslos
an den versorgungslasten eine soziale
stadt hängt der dann aber so auch nicht
mehr funktionieren kann die ihren vivien
im augenblick kämpfen also zunächst die
gute nachricht dass durch die
digitalisierung die produktivität enorm
erhöht wird das heißt also es wird ein
wahnsinniges wirtschaftswachstum geben
und es wird wahnsinnig viel geld
generiert und jetzt stehen wir ja nur
vor der erst mal total tagen tragen wo
ich ja gesagt hab ich würde es über
finanzsteuer machen ich würde es nicht
über die besteuerung von arbeit machen
das ist ein konzept das viel zu wenig
diskutiert wird aber aus meiner sicht
von allem was ich kenne das mit abstand
spannendste konzept also maschinen feuer
ist unsinn und so wirklich das einzige
was sinnvoll ist was im augenblick die
parteien nicht aufgreifen und das zweite
ist wenn es so kommt wie sie das sagen
auf der einen seite ein heer von
komplett abgehängt
die lindt status des abgehängt science
an die kinder vererben und auf der
anderen seite die die arbeiten in
hochqualifizierten berufen und dafür
sorgen dass ihre kinder das auch machen
dann leben wir in einer furchtbaren
gesellschaft sondern entscheiden muss ja
sein dass die vernetzung nach wie vor da
ist das also ganz viele menschen die
zeitweilig von einem grundeinkommen
leben jederzeit in der lage sind in den
bereich der arbeitsgesellschaft zurück
zu wechseln
das ist eine elementare herausforderung
an ein bildungssystem
wir haben ein bildungssystem das
funktioniert über extrinsische belohnung
also in der schule lernt sich für noten
und wieder im leben vergällt wenn es
aber so ist das nur noch relativ wenig
oder nicht mehr die hälfte der menschen
für geld in solchen verhältnissen
arbeiten werden dann müssen ja auch die
anderen genug pläne und ideen haben denn
arbeit und lohn arbeitet nicht dasselbe
aber was sollte mit dem selbstwertgefühl
wenn ich eben eine arbeit habe die
sozusagen mit dem maßstab geld und
beschäftigung nicht mehr gedeckt ist
naja gewährleisten geschichte der
menschheit anguckt ist das kein
schlimmer zustand also im alten
griechenland haben all die leute die die
demokratie erfunden haben unter wählen
durften selbstverständlich nicht
gearbeitet
ja also der freie wille aber noch
niemand geschafft
aber der hat für die arbeit hat er die
frauen die ausländer und die sklaven und
also das was in zukunft die computer und
die roboter seien also insofern ist die
vorstellung einer gesellschaft in der
viele menschen mich arbeiten
das ist ein alter menschheitstraum die
linke hat
zu beginn der industriellen revolution
davon geträumt die maschinen arbeiten
die arbeiter sind also wenn der
busfahrer ja jetzt von morgen an nicht
mehr bus fahren muss aber das gleiche
einkommen wie käme würde der sich
automatisch wertlos führen würde ich
sagen es ist eine frage dessen was er
noch für pläne hat ja und was für ein
bildungssystem hat wie stark seine
motivation sind wie viel man dafür getan
hat wieviel angebote die gesellschaft
bereitstellt und so weiter und so weiter
also das was wir hier haben dieses
lohnarbeit leistungssystem das ist 200
jahre alt in der geschichte der
menschheit ist eine kleine synkope und
wir werden wieder in eine gesellschaft
kommen die wieder ähnlich funktioniert
wie frühere gesagt das heißt die frage
vor der wir stehen ist die wie wir das
wie wir das ohne große verwerfungen ohne
große unruhen auch bewältigen diese
herausforderung also unser verhältnis
zur arbeit neue arbeit neu auszurichten
und gleichzeitig die verteilungsfrage
anders zu lösen als im augenblick gelöst
ist also wenn wir die verteilungsfrage
nicht anders lösen
dann klicken hier können sie die
berühmte fähre zwischen arm und reich
noch eklatanter auseinander die
digitalisierung ist der
brandbeschleuniger dann für diese
entwicklung dann haben wir eine riesige
zahl von abgehängten in der gesellschaft
ein enormes unzufriedenheit potenzial
und ich will einfach verhindern dass sie
bei der ersten oder bei der zweiten
industriellen revolution es erste
totalkatastrophe kommen muss bis man
daraus lernt und die weichen richtig
stellt und wenn ich den optimismus mich
hätte dass wir das hinkriegen können er
und nicht auch versuchen würde von
meiner seite auf die politik einzuwirken
dass ernst zu nehmen und den leuten
nicht dadurch oder das gleiche gilt für
die wirtschaft außen hin weiter gerade
genannt hin zu gehen und sagen es läuft
doch alles gut dann wird das entsetzen
und das erwachen umso größer sein die
digitalisierung beinhaltet in der tat
die faust dass wir in eine sehr gute
gesellschaft kommt das potenzial ist da
und ich möchte dass sie auf dem weg
dahin nicht zu tief durch tal der tränen
was ist heute setzt ja voraus dass
politik aber auch die gesellschaft
insgesamt will das jetzt nicht mehr auf
die politik sie beschrieben dass die
einfach einen langfristigen ansatz
verfolgt als im augenblick erkennbar wo
man dann tatsächlich und wieso in der
tagespolitik und im klein-klein gefangen
ist auch die politik
da kann man ja fast mitleid haben dass
eben diese etwas größeren würfe
ausbleiben
es ist so taktik ist wenn man überlegt
was sie situativ am besten und strategie
ist wenn man sich ein ziel wird und sagt
was sind die zehn frische die ich machen
muss um das ziel zu erreichen über jahre
hinweg und diese als zweiter art von vor
die täter sucht strategische politik
haben wir nicht mehr das ist aber nicht
nur in deutschland so das ist in anderen
europäischen ländern genau dasselbe
wir haben also eine diktatur der taktik
über die strategie des weißen linien der
medien mit noch mit dem blut seiner
mediengewerkschaft natürlich also wenn
sie auch nur einen schritt von diesen
zehn jetzt gehen soll also wenn sie in
diesem wahlkampf als vertreter einer
großen partei das wort grundeinkommen in
den mund nehmen dann haben sie sofort
ein riesiges aufregung potentaten leben
wir in einem land wo alle immer wissen
wo sie geben sind ja und ich sage es
sehr interessant warum ist denn dafür
was könnte denn und bauen sagte er das
haben wir ja nicht also wer etwas
erreichen will der sucht sich ziele und
wer das verhindern will der hat gründe
und wir leben in einem land in dem
verstärkt durch die medien eine diktatur
der gründe über die viele vorliegt und
weil die politiker das wissen sie immer
den risikolosen weg nun leben wir in
einer alternden gesellschaft in
deutschland und alternde gesellschaften
sind ja nicht dafür bekannt dass sie
besonders reformfreudig und
zukunftsfähig sind ist das ein ballast
mit dem wir zurechtkommen müssen
ja man kann das mit dem lachen und einem
weinenden auge gesehen auf der einen
seite hat eine überalterte gesellschaft
die auch einen vorteil sie ist relativ
friedlich also die größte kriegsgefahr
und die größten unruhen haben sie in den
gesellschaften in dem sie besonders
viele junge männer ohne pläne ideen für
den tag haben
das haben wir in der geschichte häufig
erlebt also lange in ihren 100
auch einer der gründe für für den ersten
weltkrieg
auf der anderen seite haben sie
natürlich recht weitete gesellschaften
so konservativ sie neigen zur
besitzstandswahrung sie wollen weniger
veränderungen haben und ist es so dass
wir uns die veränderung der
digitalisierung nicht aussuchen können
wir können ja nicht sagen jetzt in die
decke über den kopf und wir nämlich
daran teil und der rest der welt
digitalisiert sich das heißt also wir
müssen damit machen und deswegen ist es
natürlich wichtig dass wir trotz unserer
konservativen mentalität trotzdem viele
mehr zu verlieren haben diese
entwicklung nicht mit geschlossenen
augen machen sondern sehenden auges und
das heißt dass wir all die wichtigen
politischen und sozialen umgestaltungen
aktiv angehen
die wir angehen müssen damit wir auch in
zukunft in einer lebenswerten
gesellschaft bei uns in deutschland und
in europa nehmen wir müssen da die
treibende kraft sein sind dass die
parteien sind dass verbände
gewerkschaften sind dass philosophen
er wird uns auf jeden fall bei uns so
dass die gewerkschaften gegenwärtig
überhaupt nicht die treibende kraft sind
die parteien sind das auch nicht wäre
leben in einen politischen stillstand
den wir betrieben haben
aber ich würde mir natürlich wünschen
die parteien hätten mehr mut und ich
glaube dass ein politiker die rede mut
hätte all diese großen veränderungen
anzusprechen dass er tatsächlich
wesentlich mehr erfolg haben würde als
im augenblick selber glaubt mit diesen
positiven ausblick oder dieser hoffnung
die sie ihre ausgeführt haben sind wir
am ende des gesprächs ich bedanke mich
hier sehr herzlich für das gespräch mit
ihnen werde
[Musik]
[Applaus]